hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
new Game of Thrones to break down so I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
legends of Winterfell because there's
gonna be such an important place in the
final battle with the night king or at
least one of the final battles there's
still lots of theories about where the
actual final battle will take place it's
just that we know that they're going to
be at least two big battles one of them
taking place at Winterfell
which they're in the process of filming
right now then eventually at King's
Landing so this will mostly cover what's
happening way up in the north at
Winterfell because you have everybody
that's either team to Narus or team
Stark massing in the first couple of
episodes everyone's probably going to
roll in like Jamie is headed towards
Winterfell but you have to get through
all the really big introductions first
like Daenerys and Jon Snow will probably
be there in the first episode so one
thing at a time you don't want to crowd
that really big moment of a dragon
coming back to Winterfell and it's not
the first time that a dragon has been to
Winterfell which is where we get into
some of the secrets and old tales about
things that happened at Winterfell
involving dragons that might help them
out in addition to the actual keep
itself like there are many different
parts of Winterfell that were built over
the ages some of them will be more
useful in the fight against the night
Kings army than others one of the
biggest mythological legends that people
talk about when they talk about
Winterfell is the idea that there might
be a clutch of dragon eggs buried
beneath it that's left over from some
ancient time in history like Winterfell
itself is built on hot springs so it's
not too hard to believe that there might
be dragon eggs laid somewhere beneath it
because Dragons used to cover the earth
so it would make sense that at some
point a dragon was there but the really
cool thing that's happened to the last
couple of years is that we've gotten
some extra information that sort of
clarifies in places the specific
location of where those dragon eggs are
supposed to be so if you haven't read it
world of Ice and Fire is just the sort
of history compendium that Martin worked
on with Elio and Linda
that covers a whole bunch of errata
that's not necessarily connected to
what's going on in the show right now
but it's connected to really big things
that they talked about in the history of
the books some of which they can
actually pick up on in the prequel
series when that starts in a couple
years we talked about how the dance of
the Dragons is one of the leading
candidates for the time period that
they'll cover during the prequel series
during that period Jake Harris velaryon
who was a prince of the blacks like
there was a blacks versus the Greens two
sides of House Targaryen that were
warring over the succession he had a
dragon named vormax he flew on that to
the north to secure the loyalty of the
Lord in the north of the time named
Creegan stark for the side of the blacks
like declare for the blacks and he
granted them a Targaryen princess
because he was unwed at the time while
he was there it was rumored that vormax
laid dragon eggs in the crypts at
Winterfell close to the hot springs so
when people talk about dragon eggs being
laid beneath Winterfell they just in a
more recent story detailed how that
might have happened and while there been
a lot of rumors about what might happen
with Dragons after a Song of Ice and
Fire series like after they defeat the
night King will dragons come back how
many more dragons are going to die
during the battle but you still have
drogon and regal it's possible that they
could lay dragon eggs together if we
talked a little bit about the biology of
dragons they have a fluid sexuality they
can actually switch sexes those two
dragons could mate together and create
more dragon eggs
but again dragons used to cover the
earth so they're probably petrified
dragon eggs all over the place Daenerys
is dragon eggs during season one they
were petrified before she used blood
magic to hatch them so to speak so that
was a bit of a special situation
normally dragon eggs are not petrified
but you can kind of see why it's cool
that the dance of the Dragons might be
one of the prequel series because it
ties to what's going on in present-day
the idea that there is this dragon
legacy at Winterfell
even though Jon Snow in present day is
the dragon legacy it just takes a
different form getting into more of the
big battle with the night king in his
army of the Dead if you look at the
structure of Winterfell here the best
example for the night Kings path of
attack is actually when Stannis tried to
attack the Bolton's who had controlled
Winterfell at the end of season five
look at how they're attacking from the
wood he
if you're not super familiar with the
geography of Winterfell the north side
here that Stannis and his army are
looking at is the hunters gate this is
the broken tower over on the right side
here the first keep the oldest part of
Winterfell this is where bran was pushed
out the window by Jamie I'm sure
there'll be a funny conversation about
that when they talk about the defense of
Winterfell like which buildings will be
able to hold up better than others you
can see the godswood in the heart tree
over on the left side here so just
remember that most of the time when
you're seeing Winterfell you're actually
seeing it from the south view like when
Arya Stark rides up on the hill here
she's looking at the South Gate so I
would say that the knight King would
mostly attack from the north from
Stannis's position here but you have to
imagine that his army is a hundred
thousand-plus
strong it'll probably be even stronger
by the time he winds his way down to
Winterfell
so he'll actually be able to encircle
the entire castle so whereas a normal
army would either attack from the south
or the north the night king could
probably do the exact same thing they
did during episode six when they have a
small party stuck in the middle of the
lake imagine that only Winterfell is now
the rock in the middle of the lake and
everybody is stuck inside although when
you think about it this is a shot from
episode one they do have a lot of armies
that are massing they have the unsullied
they have the Dothraki so they're
actually gonna be positioned outside the
castle it's not like every single person
who's team star core team Daenerys is
gonna be inside the walls of Winterfell
but again that's another big question -
is this how bigger the dragons going to
be will they actually be able to fit
inside the walls at Winterfell
especially when they arrive you don't
forget about preparing for battle just
arriving and having all those
pleasantries where Daenerys has to meet
Sansa the Lords of the north the Lords
of the north are a whole other story too
because they hate anybody with a
Targaryen name the godswood is full of
too many trees in the South yard in the
north yard are full of too many people
preparing armor just getting things
ready all the blacksmith the horses so
it just seems like it from a practical
perspective the Daenerys will have to
land outside the castle walls even
though it would be pretty badass to see
him perched on one of the walls of
Winterfell as big as they are he would
just bring one of those outer walls
crumbling down if he tried to perch on
top of it
but the other really cool thing you may
have heard Maisie Williams just did
another interview where she pretty much
confirmed that we're gonna get an April
premiere 2019 for season 8 which
everybody believed I did a video sort of
explaining the emmys timeline there's
actually a cut-off date where people
have to start posting a certain number
of episodes before they're eligible for
Emmys that year in Game of Thrones
doesn't wanna have to sit out a year for
the Emmys for their final season which
basically means that they have to start
airing episodes bare minimum by the
third week in April but I don't think
that they're gonna wait that long
normally it used to premiere earlier in
April and they'll probably just retake
that because an edition Maisie Williams
also said that they would finish filming
in December which flies in the face of
everything else that all the other cast
members have said principal photography
is supposed to wrap at the beginning of
the summer
so when Maisie Williams says that
they're going to finish filming in
December which she's probably talking
about is the pickup's like they'll
finish principal photography early on
they'll be in post-production for most
of the year and then they'll just like
find little inserts that they need or
takes that they want to do better or
things that they want to change the
biggest thing that they could possibly
wait to film til the end of the year
would be the actual ending like they
just want to stave that off as long as
possible just to prevent any potential
spoilers most of that will probably be
filmed indoors just because it's easier
to control spoilers from getting out
then when you're filming in broad
daylight
like they're filming the Battle of
Winterfell right now it's pretty easy to
see what's going on but let me know in
the comments knowing now that there was
potentially a clutch of dragon eggs that
was laid during the time of the dance of
the dragons which wasn't that long ago
from present day on the show don't you
actually want to see them do that for
the TV show and I know we haven't talked
too much about the actual dance of the
Dragons because it's pretty complicated
there are many many Targaryens during
this period
Martin's really only covered it in a
couple different novellas he might do
just a little bit more but for the most
part it sounds like the leading
candidate for the actual prequel series
but we're not gonna get too much
more information about that until after
the final season has aired but just
don't be surprised if they filmed pilots
for a number of different prequel series
and then watch those and decide which is
the strongest like right now it's still
in the script phase like they're reading
the scripts for all the different ideas
then they'll start filming the ones that
they think are the strongest there's a
new round of the DVD giveaway - all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and share the video using those tools on
the watch page congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last video
chicane Madison please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here to watch Peter Dinklage and
George art Martin talked about the
bittersweet ending that they have in
mind for Game of Thrones and click here
to learn more about what's going on with
the premiere date thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight